so like you work with you know Studio
Orange right now which you know I I
would say I think it's like the premiere
studio for 3D like 3D animation I mean
you uh City Orange has made shows like
you know B Stars Trigun a second akuni
as well I believe as well and I feel
like Studio orange is like leading the
charge to like make sure that 3D
animation gets a good rep yeah
especially from anime definitely
um how much exposure do you get from the
fan base in terms of their
preconceptions with 3D anime I know um I
mean it's a really great honor that a
lot of fans consider that's that yeah um
from our perspective we actually feel a
little bit more different we're just
using as a tool right to because all our
CEOs animator right and he wants to just
fully Express
um whatever he wants to do so he's just
we're just using that as a tool oh okay
okay so there wasn't was there ever like
a conscious choice of like this is why
we're using 3D or was it just kind of
like it just kind of sense so to be um
as the studio was found about one
animator yeah he was working for a jump
on among artists as an assistant back
then he found Pixar he found truck Toy
Story and he's finally got this what he
called Clarity that yeah
animation from there right right oh
that's interesting because I know like a
lot of well a lot of Japanese anime in
the animation industry is based around
2D anime so I think it's cool that you
know there's a lot there's been a lot of
experimentation done with 3D animation
in the past industry and I feel like
Studio orange just ends up doing things
a little bit differently yeah you guys
kind of just like figured it out I guess
it's like the best way to put it like
because you know this there's been like
even if you go back to like early 2000s
right there were not full 3D anime but
you know definitely like a lot of 3D
artists working on like backgrounds or
like you know action sequences and stuff
like that but there were so many shows
in my opinion whereas it was very
obvious yeah that there was this is 3D
and then everything else is in 2D right
but there's something about the worker
Studio orange where it almost blurs that
line yeah to the point where sometimes
I'm watching it and I almost forget that
it's actually 3D yeah if that makes
sense so it's like do do you think
there's like some kind of a what's
what's your secret yeah what's the
secret
like what what makes Studio orange just
like stand out so much in the field
actually to any business partner what I
explained is that we're actually the
hentai of anime industry so hentai
[Applause]
yeah okay
so we're the psychopath where The
Maniacs yeah right so like what which
okay let's there's so much I want to ask
but in terms of like can you like
elaborate on that what do you do
differently uh in terms of like everyone
else right now in the industry in your
minds that makes CD orange work stand
out uh I mean nowadays um there's so
many actually CD Studios actually
starting to rise right I mean Dragon
Ball super amazing yeah um Sam slam dunk
that's blew my mind yeah yeah I haven't
seen that have you seen that yeah I I
saw bits and pieces of it but I haven't
actually seen the full movie it walks
yeah I've only heard amazing things
about it okay because yeah every time I
see like 3D like anime I'm not gonna lie
part of my brain is like oh no
I had that exact same reaction when I
saw that b Stars was getting an anime
yeah right because like compared to the
manga which is like itagi part of style
is very sketchy and like very rough like
clearly just like you know rougher
around the edges but in the best way
possible and then when I heard that oh B
stars is getting anime and as a monger
fan I was like this is great I [__]
love these stars and then the moment I
saw the trailer I was like there was a
part of me that was like oh no
it's in 3D but then when I saw the
studio orange name I was like okay yeah
you know what there's a chance that'll
be good and thankfully [__] amazing
thank you yeah absolutely incredible I
think it is made up um we focus on the
what is the essence of that right so B
Stars the drawing is really fantastic
but there's to recreate that and CG it's
possible but it's easy there's a lot of
um tools that you need so it's gonna
cost a lot of money to recreate that
yeah so what is the essence what can we
pick out to the essence and whatever
that's possible within that realm right
now to adapt it I think that's really
really great at I'm curious do you think
in your opinion is 3D animation harder
than 2D anime or is it just that they
have different strengths rather than one
being harder than the other they
definitely have different strengths
right hand drawing I mean if you have a
pencil and paper you just start yeah um
with whatever skill you have and
Imagination yeah 3D you have to have a
tool so it's all based on formulas and
numbers and stuff right because I feel
like a lot of the preconception
especially with a lot of you know people
who watch anime is that you know we've
seen I guess the evolution of the use of
3D and Anime and a lot of the times they
always felt like 3D was used maybe it's
as like a tool that meant you know you
had to put less work in uh rather than
costs and to cut production time and
stuff like that but I think one thing
that really said to you orange apart is
that instead of using it as like kind of
like a cost cutting technique you kind
of like use the tool to its fullest
potential which we see with of a lot of
your work and I was wondering did that
philosophy like come right at the get-go
or was it just you know you see yo being
like I want to do 3D this is the way
forward I mean it started over that I'm
on the 3D
um so his professional work I don't know
a lot of people who watches this um but
there's a show called zoids oh
[Music]
and Japan Deutsch was equivalent to a
reboot oh okay yeah what so what like
I'm curious what is your opinion of the
evolution of like the use of 3D in anime
from like the past like decade or so
because we've we see it quite a lot more
often now
Evolution that's a hard question yeah
um I think really what Japan needed was
the budget time to really grow I mean
Hollywood had twice not twice I mean
digits different a budget yeah yeah yeah
and everything was in English so she's
just after I was all primarily English
right right oh yeah Japan needed to
adapt to that so we're starting off
later than the English first before you
can even start modeling right yeah yeah
I mean our CEO bought this um 30k
software back then right and the manual
was all English so he's like doing
dictionary oh [__] oh my God okay yeah
that'll take a while yeah because I
remember like growing back uh going back
to like growing up and down me in like
the mid-2000s I remember like was it
like Studio Gonzo or something that used
a lot of 3D also go hands as well go
hands as well yeah Gonzo did like gants
yep they did uh as well and they had
like the 3D back then was let's say very
different from what it like what it
looks like now and just seeing the
progression of 3D people were still
always complain about 3D but I feel like
now is getting to the point where it's
becoming a lot less noticeable yeah
which is I think is a which I think is
the big thing would you say a lot of
that is just the industry kind of like
learning the software properly and
seeing how it's like how knowing how to
use it properly yeah I think uh over
overall throughout the entire industry
starting to reach that point the
breaking point right everything is
starting to evolve right what what do
you think is like the secrets like
to making something that to integrating
3D into anime because I feel like Studio
orange do the best so yeah like again it
was that like as I was saying with B
Stars it's like it's almost it's you
know it's 3D but there's a feeling and I
don't know if it's like the movement or
the the coloring the shading whatever it
might be that just makes it it makes you
forget it's 3D and I think that's the
best 3D in anime where it's like it
doesn't it there isn't this like weird
thought in the back of your head of I'm
watching a 3D anime yeah I'm just
watching a good anime all right 60 FPS
in it 60 60fps anime who would have
thought
I better get a program yeah right